what the [ __ ] can you believe it what
it's him
it's me it's fat man
uh welcome to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i'm mark bernard
hey hello everybody it's saturday night
uh in any decent world we'd be out
partying
[ __ ] dancing as we used to back in
the day but instead
give another angle andrew so they could
see the [ __ ] bulletproof shield
indeed
this is so that me and mark can talk to
one another and
sneeze and spit into this [ __ ] salad
bar
sneeze guard here that jc's installed so
that we could stand behind the bar again
our place where we always stand
ensconced
behind the bar anew uh yes we're still
dealing with the age of covet out here
in california
it's real [ __ ] bad yeah it's no joke
yeah it's crazy
um so much so that we're as californians
who came from the east coast were like
perhaps it's time to go home it's like
should we pack up the truck honey who
got it beverly i've heard they've
flattened a curb or two so
uh but uh [ __ ] all that man tonight
we're gonna gather we're gonna talk
about some [ __ ] fun
and probably not so fun [ __ ] a little
bit of not so fun [ __ ] in the news man
all the news that's fit to print we're
gonna handle right here on fat man
beyond and stuff but first
we have to take care of some business
a little bit of housekeeping a little
bit of housekeeping kids
in the world of media there are those
that make
things and there are those who pay for
the things that are made
tonight someone is paying for something
that's right normally we do free shows
out the ass but tonight
we have a sponsor i'm proud to announce
we have a sponsor mark
is even prouder i am and it's still free
for you
it's just somebody else is paying for
your free there you go so enjoy it if
you're ever sitting there going boy i
hope these guys are rewarded for their
time
you're about to reward us by listening
listening to this ad right here
um hey if you're anything like me kevin
smith yeah cool guy
cool cool guy kevin smith no no if i'm
anything like you you're a cool guy
oh i was saying cool guy kevin smith
sometimes cool guys
get a little hot though a little hot
under the collar especially summer
in los angeles schwitzy as they say it
was 115 degrees by my house you're not
kidding i didn't hike running today
because i was like forget it man there's
a hundred it was 103 i looked at the
temperature and that was at 11 30.
that ain't right it's not right at all
guess what happens to
any normally function human being but
particularly
men of girth indeed in weather like that
there's some sweat
and lots of it you know how you can
eradicate some of that sweat
uh a series of complicated shots into
your
armpits i think that's what simon pegg
did uh yes
however is that what we're saying what's
the [ __ ] they put in the head that like
makes your
your your brow not stretch women do it
uh botox botox if you inject botox into
your armpits they won't sweat for like
six months
really that's what simon pegg told me i
was like why do you know that he's like
i'm a big sweater
like a big sweater but there's a cheaper
way to go there's a
way cheaper way mark's going to tell you
about it right now
native deodorant like if you are
anything like me especially if you're on
any kind of kind of weight loss journey
you're very used to reading the labels
of [ __ ] right you like looking for
calories and carbohydrates and
and what'll be good for you what'll be
bad for you native deodorant you look at
their [ __ ]
ingredient thing stuff like cocoa butter
oh stuff like mint
basically it's [ __ ] that you would eat
in any other form now it's compressed
into a bar that you wipe under your arms
i'm in no aluminium i like to say it the
british way that's the british way what
mark means translated for our american
audience is no aluminum
no aluminum it's got [ __ ] coco
coconut oil shea butter tapioca starch
son
delicious i'd be eating that that's
vegan [ __ ] yes
and with over 10 different scents
including seasonal
scents maybe there's a minty holly berry
thing for
that's a good idea so they altered up
it's not just like the the common speed
stick by men and son
your whole life ever you get like
different flavors if you want to get
some [ __ ] pumpkin spice to dash under
your arms
i bet you they got one you know be
following you yoga moms
so where you going baby yeah they'd
leave starbucks to be like you smell
like pumpkin spice like you're not
sweating but you smell delicious you
smell like a drive-through that i want
to drive through
what's that smell it smells like pumpkin
spice no
that's sweat that's native deodorant
um so yeah they got all kinds of
different flavors flavors
scents because it's delicious [ __ ] man
they're making out of the good
eating stuff you might lick an armpit if
they're wearing native
you might and hey what it's risk free to
try
you know [ __ ] free 30-day returns and
exchanges
see why so many people have like 14 000
five-star reviews
whoa i know right that's pretty good
huge so hey do what i did
make the switch to native today and
going to nativedeo.com
fatman or use a promo code fatman at
checkout
and get 20 off your first order that's
nativedeo.com
20 or use the promo code fat man at
checkout for 20
off your first order uh kids what are
you waiting for
we're not starting the show until you go
order it so
we got to ticker up here we'll wait yes
we're going to see the numbers as soon
as we hit 10 000 units
we'll start the show yeah so wait
and that's one we're on our way
uh native kids if you like fat man
beyond
go support the good folks at native just
like mark said for heaven's sakes man
there's graphics you putting graphics up
jc
got graphics
fat nativedo.com native deo
dot com slash fat man that's gonna get
you
hooked right up i mean i'm tired of
stinking native
i know you're not leaving the house much
but do this for you yeah
i mean yeah that's true just because
like you know you're not in an office
building
yeah slap some natives you're with the
people who live in your house with you
man like especially in the summer
holy [ __ ] done stanking go native
there i just come up with their campaign
nice and scene
uh there it is folks uh thank you and
good night no the good folks at native
sponsoring today's edition tonight's
edition
of fat man beyond unofficial sponsor
look what we got him to try after months
of being here
and watching mark drink these uh the bud
light seltzers
i'm gonna imbibe now i'm only doing this
because there's no real water in the
place
so it was liquor or nothing so
yeah here we go
that is better isn't it though yes well
i got to give you the inside
earlier i tried one of the strawberry
and good lord
yeah i told you like don't do that he's
been saying it for months i was like the
strawberry looks good he's like no no
black cherry all the way so i had some
strawberry and it was
alarming to say the least but this black
cherry has been
it's been smooth it's nice now i never
drink kids
ever so we're in for a show i mean
one of these and you might start hearing
some truth bombs
um one of my favorite little nuggets of
historical trivia is that
drunk already look at that purifying
water is a relatively new
invention definitely in the 20th century
yes
so every army that has ever marched
anywhere
for millennia was carrying wine and beer
with them
and not water because you couldn't trust
the water in any river you went to
unless you're collecting [ __ ] rain
water every army was drunk off their
[ __ ] nuts
just saying just and it's also like
weird because that's
not i can't imagine like if you're like
i'm parched
and like a sip of beer don't do it does
it uh well cold beer would but warm beer
not too much for me but there's also
like india pale ale
is meant to be drank at sort of room
temperature is it refreshing
uh for some i don't want to drink
anything at room temperature
we've got water room damage and the idea
of like warm wine and [ __ ]
insane if you're thirsty and you're
[ __ ] marching to gallipoli
i bet you you're also drinking a nice
shiraz and let me tell you i'm i'm so
thirsty i'm drinking
beer beer water your bud light self
mud light seltzer black cherry um it's
weird to report
that i'm feeling a little tingly there's
something going on there's something to
this alcohol
mark i've been i've been waiting five
years to hear you say
i'm feeling a little tingly mark i might
pass out gonna have to uber home
um all right so we've paid our bills
we've sucked back some mead
now it's time to gather around the fire
and do what's most important
catch up how you been i've been good man
ship out of danger
i have been
the needs of the many outweigh the needs
of the few
how do you like my solution scenario
how do you like my solution remember
when he gets up and he straightens his
[ __ ] yeah and he stumbles
because he's but he's still a military
man until the end he's like i got to be
presentable for the captain
um yeah how you been
i want to put him on the glass if i put
him on the glass will you
i got some singles thank you that's what
i'm looking for
what'd you do this week uh this week was
uh
busy in the in the picard story mines oh
um making tracks into the stores making
[ __ ] tricks man
um so doing a bit of that um i had a
little of extracurricular activities
that i was doing not picard related but
still television related mark finally
had sex is what he's saying good for you
good for you took a while but [ __ ]
this colvin baby
do all this [ __ ] you've been waiting for
loving the time of copenhagen yeah um
there was something extracurricular that
wasn't picard orange it wasn't
bacard-oriented but was
television-oriented and we're not
allowed to talk about it no of course
you'll tell me later so he can't talk
about anything never um
and that i think is about it i think i
watched some [ __ ] television he
i did i watched i caught up on umbrella
academy i saw the first season of it and
the second season just dropped
um i really dug it based on the great
gerard ways book
indeed with uh with one of them moon
slash ba i think it's gabriel bar did
the art
or was it fabio moon never remember
brazilian twin artists
right it's always hard for me to the
good watch
um it was a good watch man it moved real
fast um
it didn't didn't [ __ ] hold up for a
lot of [ __ ] and it always kept on
evolving and revolving and
flipping a lot of time travel [ __ ] going
on but no it was super cool man
it was super cool what else did i do i
didn't go to the movies
uh because we don't do that anymore
nobody does that nobody does that
anymore
the scene the movie movie what do you
see
what did i watch i saw you i i'd seen
the trailer
and then i was like oh i got to watch
that one day and then i saw you tweet
about it and so i was like you know what
i am watching that
uh bass and the furies cubers oh
speedcubers
holy [ __ ] what a wonderful
for number one kids it's on netflix go
it's called speedcubers the speedcubers
the speedcubers
45-minute documentary yeah you're in and
out
not a huge commitment of time no but
every one of them 45 minutes
gold i i literally was i think i i'd we
only at home try to watch like two
episodes of a thing of days because we
don't want to like be all up in it so we
were watching the umbrella academy we
were done i was just scrolling through
netflix like
huh speedcubers what's this and the
trailer made me like get a little misty
yes and then and i always love movies
about like subcultures that i don't know
anything about
you know it's like look this is a thing
that apparently thousands of people are
involved in
as we're watching the daca i say to
jennifer my wife i'm like there is a
convention
for everything the [ __ ] everything
has its own con
it was amazing like there was this whole
world where like it's not even like oh
there's a couple
you know [ __ ] 50 people in a room and
a holiday inn they had a [ __ ]
ballroom and then melbourne
they filled like a an indoor arena in
australia
with like the best rubik's cubers in the
world and these [ __ ] are
serious
it's crazy these cubers are there's
three by three which is the standard
rubik's cube we all know
i'm getting slurry already stay in a
rubik's cube remember rubik
there's 4x4 they got in the colors and
do it um they'd have a 4x4 which is like
harder
and it keeps going up but the classic
three by three is the
right still the gold standard and then
there's like three by three blindfolded
or eyes closed
and one-handed one-handed some of these
people they show them like
[ __ ] all they do is before they go
they're just like the one character max
one character the one kid max
was constantly like the way people do
poker chips in their finger he was
constantly working it
and before in the competition before
like you know because they've got a
cover on the cube and then
before they go they do a cube
just to like limber up there to limber
up and it's [ __ ] and i'm not
bullshitting you they solve a rubik's
cube in under 10 seconds
yeah just to warm up and then the real
event is trying to solve it in less time
than that so
you know the record was like six seconds
and change yeah
it and it's maddening like madness
watching these cats
they get to look at the cube every side
for a second to see where everything is
and then they put it down they put their
fingers on a thing and then the timer
begins and bam they pick it up and they
[ __ ] go and it's
it is crazy to [ __ ] watch so if it
was just about that alone
i would have been like this is [ __ ]
great like who knew about this [ __ ]
but the human story of this 45 minute
documentary
had me bawling the whole [ __ ] way
through yeah yeah it was
it's incredibly emotional and because
it's about these
two competitors and these two guys who
live on opposite sides of the world
um one of which is on the autistic
spectrum
and like not to spoil too much about
what happens in the documentary but like
you begin to understand why he has a
gift for this
but you couldn't have forecasted what
it's doing for him
or his family that's what [ __ ] moved
me beyond tears and i'm sure you know
it's something mark is familiar with on
a regular basis my sister
her eldest daughter is also on the
spectrum and whatnot and the whole time
i talked to my sister afterwards just to
be like
you got to watch this doc because
all i could think as i was watching it
the whole way are these
amazing parents who i never i knew i
could never be
the amount of patients and that must you
fall into you as well
it was mind-bending to me that
everything i ever took at van
granted took for granted as a parent
dopey [ __ ] it was a
monument in this household like the
thing that
like had me bawling was i mean the whole
thing i was crying
but they talked about how max who's the
kid on the spectrum
he loves the other kid alex who is a
world champion
from australia and he's seen him online
like he was for whatever reason he
responded to him
his you know knew all his records and
[ __ ] the way i was in the gretzky for a
minute
this cat was like that's how he was into
this cat alex
so they go to an event
the first time with with their son max
who's like
way into cubing and he can do it pretty
fast at this point
but they're in the audience and max
is pointing and going that's alex
and the parents in the documentary
relate in the story and they're talking
about
like you don't understand that is
everything because apparently kids on
the spectrum that's not a thing
and they were explaining how it was and
i couldn't i was sucking wind it was so
beautiful and it made me like
like just think about all the [ __ ]
raising a kid that like i took for
granted like that's what they do
and these parents were like
the mom told us tells a story about how
like in the once they got the kid
diagnosed and stuff
you know they were like he's he's just
in his own little world
and she said that was frustrating and so
one day
she just started doing exactly what he
did laying down with him and stuff
imitated behavior and slowly over the
course of time he like held her hand
and like closed the tent to keep dad out
and stuff and like
saw her and how elated and
and like the you know it's like they
talk about it
as if like and then the cancer was cured
and stuff it's just
so incredibly moving and the very human
story of
like this kid alex who was the world
champion
becoming friends with max an unlikely
friendship but max is one by one picking
off
alex's records yeah and alex
in any other if alex was anyone but an
australian
and maybe a canadian there would be no
doc or it would be a different doc about
how alex is a real prick
to this angelic max kid who looks up to
him and [ __ ]
it is beautiful i'm telling you like if
it was five hours it'd be worth your
time
45 minutes you'll be out of this thing
in no time and you will
feel better as a human being it was one
of the most engaging things i've watched
throughout the entire
quarantine and i literally just stumbled
on it at random me too
i saw a trailer and i was like huh that
looks interesting and then when i saw
your
tweet about it i was like well mark
belch is for it let's watch it and
[ __ ] was it great man yeah it reminded
me a lot of
searching for bobby fischer did you ever
which is
the most wonderful thing the pots are
zach the potzer's actually ruin your
game remember that's what he tells him
that's ben kingsley but like the
it's the lowest stakes in the world like
there's there's no comet hurtling
towards earth there's no
train that's got no brakes it's
literally like this little kid
is a chess prodigy and can his parents
encourage that excellence while still
retaining
what makes a kid a kid and it's the sort
of
tug of war between like coaches and
parents and
and schools and excellence and legacy
and all this stuff and just this kid who
wants to be nine years old
yeah who just happens to be brilliant
just happens to be brilliant at it
and you know like is he having fun doing
it well nobody who's having fun can be
good
it's a little like amadeus that way yeah
it's like oh amadex is having too much
fun like music is serious business like
well why is he
like having sex with people under the
table right right but yeah searching for
bobby fischer and speedcubers would be
an amazing double feature on like some
saturday when you just want to feel
really good about the world
yes yes one's very old
from the 90s from the 90s but one just
happened recently
um but yeah a middle-aged ben kingsley
that's how old it is
the foster jack they ruin your game and
a youngest
name do me a favor look up the kid's
name and bobby
searching for bobby fischer they're
potzers
is it zack jack [ __ ]
he's the main character uh um weight
goodness is josh
josh wait the boxers josh they're
posters josh for the ruin your game
josh that's it um that is worth watching
and then the other thing i watched just
before i come here was a movie that i
learned about in sundance right before
[ __ ] covid started happening and
stuff back in january
this movie called spree hmm it's
genius it's it's uh basically about
social media and [ __ ] like people
desperate to be like famous and [ __ ]
but spree is like an uber or a um
lyft like car app service and there's
this kid who
like goes on a killing spree while
driving for spree
and he's live streaming it the whole
time wow it's got i didn't you know i'm
not
overly familiar with stranger things but
the
joe kiri piri okay good hair
it's so weird that's not the first thing
i would have thought about him but yes
you're right he did have good hair
um he he's in it as the lead and it's a
i'm not saying it's a one-man show
because shasir's ma sashir zamata's in
issues and yo-go's with us from snow
um and other people are in it as well
but it
is primarily this dude talking to
cameras that are mounted all around his
car
and talking to like a social media crowd
that doesn't really exist
but it's definitely worth watching it it
was enjoyable as hell i thought
where can one find i found it on itunes
so it was a rental for me brand new
release
um totally worth watching then last week
weekend i watched there's a 10 hour
documentary
called the con oh my which was about
the housing market collapse in 2008.
10 hours [ __ ] fascinating because
it's all predicated on the story of this
poor old woman who was like 90 in
baltimore
and she had got sucked into this
[ __ ] you know housing like we'll loan
you money and then you put up your house
but the
[ __ ] difference between what the
house was worth and
what they signed for you know is like
huge
so the they put a notice on her door her
husband had passed away their house was
paid for
um they put a notice on a door
foreclosure notice
then when the police came back you know
like few days later to be like i'm sorry
we have to escort you out of your house
she [ __ ] shot herself in the chest
it's 90 year old woman
and so you know they brought it up in
congress
during the hearings you know when they
tried to go after the banks and stuff
but the filmmaker was just like it just
made me so angry and i wanted to know
like why
this dude went like he was not even a
journalist but he went deep diving
turns out she probably didn't even sign
a [ __ ] loan because this company was
like literally
forging people's signatures they could
like take a loan out in your name
because the banks were you know it
doesn't matter just get a loan if you
couldn't get somebody to sign up for one
of these loans
you're going to make 5 000 bucks so they
were pushing people under the [ __ ]
bus
willingly first they went out and they
cold call people show up their house and
be like you want to refinance your house
is worth a lot of money and stuff
then when they ran out of those people
they just started lying and just started
stealing people's identity and [ __ ] this
poor old woman [ __ ]
killed herself man because she was like
i i
can't live on the street too much pride
to like tell her friends and stuff but
you know
at first people were like well she got
horn swaggled by these
[ __ ] people and then it turns out she
might not even been hornswoggle
they might have literally [ __ ] robbed
her like in
without a gun just by using some [ __ ]
paperwork it's fascinating but it wasn't
on any server
it was like you had to sign up to watch
it
um but man it was [ __ ] fascinating
and [ __ ] and you know
it's it's kind of like the big short but
not funny
no steve carell to like you know [ __ ]
make things better and [ __ ] but i that
was a decent
pretty pretty decent watch well done and
gripping as well
i didn't imagine i could ever watch 10
hours on financial
news but it was put a human face on it
well done
um all right so we watched some [ __ ]
what's your excuse
what did you do for the last two weeks
um we got news kids
oh [ __ ] do we have some [ __ ] to discuss
things are happening in the world uh we
are mere
moments away from dc fandom you going uh
i'm i'm going mark's still under the
dome lucky [ __ ] you see that list of
people
that they're doing that yeah bunch of
famous people there's a whole [ __ ] ton
of famous people i mean it's
this seems to be the the finish this and
tell you how i feel about not being
invited to fandom
it seems like dc and it's funny i
remember going
sony had thrown themselves a convention
like seven or eight years ago yeah in
vegas
it was like a playstation convention
it's invited you know 20 000 people and
they all showed up to play games and
hear news and stuff and i was like you
know we are probably in a world in which
giant brands will stop coming to say
e3 or comic-con and just throw their own
[ __ ] convention
like disney does like disney does you
know and like at what point well you
just see a marvel convention where they
just
tell you everything about marvel not at
d23 but at their own [ __ ] thing
true and with the with the fact that was
no comic-con
or at least the comic-con that there was
um did not
generate the excitement that they had
hoped it would right
dc was a well [ __ ] it let's throw our
own convention and so it's the dc
fan dome and i'm moderating uh one panel
about a deathstroke movie that came out
or the one that just came out
yeah which uh knights and dragons i
think it's called um and i had a good
time like i
i didn't know anybody on the panel like
they were all just [ __ ] newcomers to
me but i was like you know what
[ __ ] it let's talk about this thing for
a while and they were all super cool
um and i might pop up elsewhere in said
fandom
uh one cannot say it's a secret
would i know i don't think so you ever
told me no but
one more thing for after keeping a lot
[ __ ] hidden these days
that's what happened it feels like
there's something between us mark uh you
know
but i can't see it yes but
yet it's there um all right [ __ ] all
that
the dc fandom is the 22nd of august hold
on let me finish this
you finished that
i do a show called fat man beyond you
[ __ ] no uh but yeah and so
it seems that a week and a half before
the fandom
some [ __ ] happened at dc comics
excellent segue yeah um
uh big news big news this week and this
big news
it's not sexy news because it doesn't
involve movie stars and [ __ ] like that
but
it's important news because it does
involve comics it very much does
um this past monday excuse me this past
monday maybe a monday ago i don't know
how time works
um warner media has a brand new
president a guy named
jason killar who came over from hulu i
believe and is now overseeing
pretty much all of warner media okay um
and has sort of i suppose at the behest
of the at t
corporate masters begun re-examining
every level of the business
both the things that warner brothers
does the things that you know
every other sort of channel that feed up
to giant warner media
including dc comics and so there was a
about a third of their workforce was
laid off um
not too long ago including bob harris
who was their editor-in-chief excellent
graphic pull look at jc getting
is that you or andrew andrew well done
and you're getting it done yeah looking
fancy and [ __ ] uh senior vp of
publishing strategy and subscribers
go ahead you got any more hank canals
um vp of marketing and creative services
jonah weiland
vp of global publishing initiatives and
digital strategy bobby chase
senior story editor brian cunningham and
executive editor mark doyle
who oversaw the role out of the black
label graphic novels
aka the batman dick book label indeed
um all those cats lost their jobs all of
them lost their jobs now that's not like
uh we're letting them go for now but
we're bringing them back when things are
better they're like you're gone forever
you're gone forever you know and and i
don't talk about
a mass firing a mass farming jim lee
still remains the cco and publisher
and there are two interim editors in
chief and mind you this is only months
after
dan de dio was shown the door as well
correct it's a lot of restructuring
going on there but the question is mark
are they restructuring are they just
getting rid of people um i think they
are
definitely shrinking their product line
um i think that you know from some
20 to 25 percent they will begin
re-examining the titles that are in the
bottom of their sales chart
sounds familiar remember the dc
explosion followed quickly by the dc
implosion yeah um and also
the dc universe app is just about dead
we knew that was coming though the
moment hbo max happened it made no sense
for him to have a
separate app and stuff so the writing on
the wall for that was
a long time coming but they officially
cut pretty much
like they've they've siphoned every
resource away from it the really weird
one to me
because i mean you know the comics i
can't answer to like if they're trimming
their line
it's like well if they're cutting their
line it sounds like they're
not going to be making as many comics as
they used to
i guess you could justify you know going
like well we don't need all the staff
what what i was surprised by was dc
direct was killed in the process dc
direct is their
home merch correct company where they
made all those batman black and white
statues
uh they made gorgeous pieces man
beautiful
stunning pieces they did those batman
the animated series of
run figures that were like expansive and
incredibly detailed i mean they've been
making
wonderful [ __ ] since like preacher
action figures
years ago and stuff and suddenly that's
all gone now
yeah it's been shuttered after 22 years
god damn it 22 [ __ ] years
older than my kid um and i think that
part of that
is clearly that warner brothers has its
own consumer products division that
makes
a bunch of [ __ ] toys that's what they
said they're like why do we need a
specialty division that makes things
we'll make them over here cheaper
because
we make more things over here right so
suddenly that went away
that went away and so you know jim lee
did an interview at hollywood reporter
with uh with boris kitt shortly after
the the round of layoffs and he sort of
addressed everything you know it's like
what are we doing with the company line
20 25 percent you know we're going to
focus more especially on the the ya
audience which is one of the two
interim editors in chief is michelle
wells who's running the y.a books
division
um
cause when i get one more of these in me
and you're gonna hear what i think about
these firings
i like it thank you um i always lock my
files remember ed asner gets drunk in
jfk and he's yelling at jack lemmon he's
like
you little weasel you looking at my
files
i'll unlock my files
later on we'll be performing more of jfk
one of my favorite films including the
joe pesci monologue there's a wise bunch
of
mystery wrapped in a riddle wrapped in
an enigma that's
well remembered i went for the most
obscure line in the scene you did you
went for the most
well-known it's probably smart um
man oh man what uh what do you think
this is
is this covid or this was long time
coming
i i think it's it's long time coming i
think that
dc is always going to be important to
warner brothers
because they still want to make movies
based on all these characters yeah
um but i think that the level at which
dc had been publishing
the things they had been publishing and
the the strategy behind their publishing
initiatives
was probably due a harsh look
i mean personally like and i feel this
way about marvel also
that they're not really doing enterprise
publishing what does that mean that
means like vertigo is enterprise
publishing
there was hey here's a new thing we're
putting into the world
we're creating ip that we can then sort
of maximize and capitalize on
in the future whereas now it's hey
there's nine batman books
we're gonna make the batman movie anyway
but you keep publishing these things
that are just
refurbishing and spit polishing and
different takes on stuff that we already
had plans for
you know like vertigo was a was a had
the capacity to be an ip generating
machine
create new things create new things
testing ground for [ __ ]
as opposed to here's a new version of an
old thing that isn't really going to
make any waves
kind of like the when they sell an
assortment of batman figures
you open up the box and it's got say 20
pieces
and 18 of them are batman in
[ __ ] scuba gear and two of them are
the figures that will sell
they're just there's just too many of
the one thing that
people aren't lying i don't want batman
and scuba gear just give me batman and
his gear and
yeah give me somebody that i have never
seen before or something super cool or
and you know marvel is as guilty of this
as anybody there's i'm sure there's at
still
this point seven different comics that
have wolverine in it
because he was the hero that people
wanted so let's give them what they want
this is all though business practices
[ __ ] i'm drunk this was all business
practices
from a time that doesn't look anything
like this time
yeah like that was that was 90s comic
book
publishing and maybe i guess this is
what this is some sort of reckoning for
like
this ain't the business anymore kids you
can't just make anything you got to make
something that sells or we're going to
cancel it
and the comic book business for a long
time has been run by people
who love the comic book business sounds
like they've got somebody
installed who's like yeah look i like
batman as much as the next guy but this
[ __ ] don't make sense because it loses
money so
i've been tasked with making it make
money it's a shame
but i guess from a corporate point of
view understandable this is what i think
though
i always lock my files no this is what i
think
i think things change
and then they go back right so you may
see
some belt tightening you may see some
like eradication
if you live long enough give it 10 years
things will shift
back to what they then call classic
dc or something like that i would be
more worried
mark if i hadn't been alive this long
and seen
many im permutations and incarnations of
the comic book marketplace
yeah i mean it all ebbs and flows and it
all comes and goes and it's all cyclical
in some fashion or another
um i do think though that the the 90s
like where dc kind of was was a 90s
renaissance
yeah to the point where bob harris was
running editorial
very true who was the architect of
pretty much all of the 90s books that
you know and love from marvel
over at marvel yeah um so i think that
maybe you know
our our weird nostalgia meter is cycling
upwards
yeah so now instead of the 90s we're
going to be nostalgic about the 2000s
and so
that's going to suck man because i liked
when everyone was astrologic about the
90s that was good for me
i started getting nostalgic about the
odds ain't got too much there for them
to be happy about
because then we start hitting jersey
girl country and they're like ugh i
ain't nostalgic
but you know they're still committed to
publishing comics they're still
committed to making you know these
characters work they're still committed
to having dc be a big part of what
warner brothers does so
the fear that someplace like warner
brothers or even disney would at some
point say
what's the point do we need to be making
comic books
so far the answer to that question is
yes they want to be making comic books
they're saying
yeah but do we want to make as many
comic books as we're making and that's
what apparently they're like let's
let's thin out the herd man totally you
know do you need to be making some giant
event thing where there's a
tertiary book that somehow vectors into
it does that make sense
or and i don't have the answers what the
or is
somebody else will um do you ever whimsy
like why don't they call me i'll fix it
you know what i'm saying like give me
let me run it for a year i'll [ __ ]
i'll do it
i thought about that once and um nobody
called me
yeah that never happened
you dream about the call but it doesn't
matter like 10 years ago when i
think you could do it um you think you
could flip the script let's say i'll
give you two years i'm
i am one of the warner's brothers you
are and so i come to you mark bernard
and i'm just like
these comic books are damnedest things
can't figure it out give you two years
to turn around make it profitable or
we're going to cancel comics forever or
dc comics i can't do nothing about
marvel
and go and i say well yakko
i feel like um because yakko wacko more
sister not
because clearly you're not the one or
sister no no no you know nothing not
not um i think it's part of it is
absolutely you have to
go back to some some formulation where
you're doing original content
something where and if it's not vertigo
i don't know what you call it and you
have to find a way to get creators
excited about making
content for you again you know and and
some of that was
you know marketing some of that was the
the share that you would give the
artists and the writers when they came
like that
one image comes along and says hey you
get to own it and then
warner brothers is like oh we're keeping
half of this you're gonna find a way to
make it attractive again
um and you know it's a thing that jeff
johns had said
you know once upon a time was like we
got to double down and we got to you
know go back to the original formulation
of who these characters were
maybe maybe that's part of it maybe you
get the like batman classic
and you get something that feels as it's
always been batman
but we've we've had 80 90 years of those
stories
true you know what's the next thing
what's the next iteration what's the
next interpretation
of folks like this and the last new
superhero we had like that captured him
spawn that like captured maybe
hellboy but i mean like
capes and tights or just like me hellboy
was like darkhorse
successful right but spawn was you know
millions of copies can you think of
another harley quinn
maybe harley quinn i mean venom yeah
venom too you know but it's it's been a
while because and with good reason
there was a creative explosion in the
you know 20s 30s 40s and then the 60s
and those things were good like there's
still strong
bones there and have stood this test of
time you know but it's you have to
leave room for the new otherwise you
know
that that's the chief critic's job is to
be in defense of the new
and if there's no new to defend and
you're just circling the wagons around
the old
then the only people who will buy it
will be the old and that's not how you
grow a business that's what i've noticed
over the years because
i don't know if anybody knows this but i
do own a comic book story the clientele
looks like me very old don't see a lot
of kids coming in you see people coming
in with their kids and they'll pick up
toys but they ain't picking up comic
books and stuff
no i mean and i think part of this
restructuring in dc
is focusing on digital because i think
that is where kids if they're going to
sample they're sampling it digitally
true and could you imagine being a
modern
child and somebody hands you a paper
comic book
what is this i know my uh you light it
on fire instantly
it's at this point look at it burn we
might need it for heat
but uh yeah my son has now started
reading the walking dead books
and that's literally only because he's
watched the show now right but i was
like hey buddy there are comics he's
like really it's like yeah no there's a
lot of them it's like how many and i
showed him that
the shelf that i have in my office like
and this is half of them like i stopped
buying it like thick as rick's dick
thick as rick's dick or shane's probably
shane yeah
can't protect your wreck from my dick
or shane is the guy who's got a small
dick but that's why he's so
[ __ ] outsized and you can't protect a
rick i can because my dick is small
i know how to use it it's not very
impressive to look at
not concerned with my own dick rick
but yeah it's parents now giving [ __ ] to
their kids who are surprised to know
that the things that they're watching
were based on comic books
feels like comic books will go the way
of records
high-end collectible stores yeah
you know i don't think and i do feel
like you know it's going to get to a
place where
a new comic book is 20 because the
marketplace is so small
they'll be able to be like oh it's small
batch man
and and people would buy it and i think
i mean at this point
how much is your average comic 4.99
we're not far away we're at a quarter of
the way
pages of content like if you told me
that spending
20 bucks would get me a hundred pages of
really good [ __ ] and that's the only way
you could get it
i'd buy it i'm in i mean i think ed
brubaker is experimenting with that now
like he's launching a whole line of
graphic novels and image
that are just graphic novels there's no
floppies just win the graphic novel
business
you gotta show up you want 15 bucks
you'll get story 15 bucks little man
putting that story
in full in your hands put that graphic
novel
in my hand indeed um so yeah comics is
is due a evolution and
these are like the uh the extinction
bursts before you get that evolution
uh take pictures kid cause kids we're
living through history right now
in so many ways uh all right sad news
uh we're sorry for all those folks that
lost their gigs and whatnot man it's a
hell of a time to be unemployed
it really is [ __ ] bad time to be out
of work man um and
thank them for all their years of good
service to dc comics
indeed particularly the good folks at dc
direct and they made some
exquisite collectibles you know and i
and if i could offer a piece of advice
as somebody who has been laid off in a
corporate wave of
belt tightening um it's a
gonna suck and it does um b give
yourself permission to feel all of it
you're gonna feel angry and hurt and sad
and
self-recrimination could i have done
more could i have whatever is it on me
or is it on them
feel it like just swallow it that's all
good and see
at some point it will be the best thing
that happened to you and you won't know
that until it's there
but there'll be some opportunity that
comes your way that you could not have
taken or would not have looked at
because you were in this job that was
paying you okay and the insurance was
good and you had a place to go every day
there was absolutely going to be
something that was better and bigger and
more awesome
down the pike so don't don't fret
believe him take it take his word for
he's a smart guy
mark bernard ladies and gentlemen the
words of wisdom whizzoned
words of wisdom jc
cameron jc jc uh what's going on in the
chat room
people are enjoying your uh budweiser
drinking my newfound freedom
yes yes that's right this bud light
seltzer if i finally unearth the real me
yeah people dig it i'm ready to tell you
all what i think
um all right next news story um staying
on the
on the dc comics um tip there was
a a apparently infamous alan moore comic
book proposal
called twilight of the superheroes um i
think i remember this
which you know was going to be a big
sort of
crossover event crossover event like
this kind of multiverse colliding like
after the crisis it was supposed to be
the next big thing
that uh was going to sort of borrowing
some ragnarok north massage
yeah north norse mythology stuff the
epic would have taken place in the
future ruled by a suit by superhero
dynasties
and chronicled the final battle between
earth's heroes both young and old
its villains and some of the aliens in
inhabiting earth twilight's framing
device included rip hunter
relaying the information regarding these
events to john constantine
um dc opted not to publish this comic
book
um the reasons why or i think lost a
time
but uh dc is putting out a new book
called
dc through the 80s the end of era's
hardcover
coming out this december and inside it
they're publishing the text
of this proposal the script that he
wrote um or the the one liner or
whatever
probably knowing alan moore was a
14-page document explaining everything
that was gonna happen do they have to
get his permission to do that
um you would think but i don't know
like i mean this is a guy who
is not shy in the least about being like
[ __ ] dc
would they really want to poke that bear
anymore i mean it's bad enough they
went and made more watchmen books you
know he was mad about that
yeah so this seems like unless he was
like yeah go ahead
in which case it's great but yeah it
feels super weird
to be publishing the thing that they
rejected him from writing
and something tells me if they asked him
he'd be like no you didn't do it the
first time
yeah [ __ ] you he seems fairly pragmatic
he does
uh will you read it of course you will i
mean i will i mean
and there's a lot of other stuff in that
book apparently you know it also
collects 80s published
issues with you know action comics
detective comics the flash jonah hex
house of mystery wonder woman sergeant
rock you know new essays from jack
harris elliott s
megan j m d matisse demitayus and andy
kubert
like it's a [ __ ] 500-page tome
omnibus
omnibus of cool [ __ ] from the 80s of
which this is a
small part but it's it is just kind of
fascinating
that you know and i personally would not
want
that kind of thing to be seen by the
public it's like yeah this is my pitch
thing i'm just trying to get a job
right and you know it does not reflect
what the final work would have been
so hey nobody needs to see the plans of
this house if you're not going to buy
the house
true it is well but that's that's just
me um well put but we're all going to
buy that book
what uh what else um i have uh i have
extolled the virtues
more than once of avatar the last
airbender yes
on this here yeah the animated series
and then of course they're making a
live-action one
they are on the netflix they're they're
sparing no expense
to make a big expensive one and they
were using the kids who made the
cartoon indeed yeah um so and that all's
well that ends well
next story something happened didn't it
it did
michael dante di martino and brian
konetsko
those are the two that created avatar
the last airbender who created yeah the
um the cartoon that aired on nickelodeon
and legend of korra as well the legend
of core was the follow-up
um they they were developing it with
with netflix uh you know and there had
been a couple of different iterations of
of this cartoon um adaptation
but last week um the two creators kind
of
publicly announced that they were
departing the show
no they did um in a statement
uh they each released their own
statements on social media
michael dimartino said when brian and i
signed on to the project in 2018 we were
hired as executive producers and
showrunners
in a joint statement for this series
netflix said it was committed to
honoring our vision
for this retelling and to supporting our
creating the series
and we expressed how excited we were for
the opportunity to be at the helm
unfortunately things did not go as we
hoped uh oh
um konetsko wrote in a separate
statement there was no follow through on
netflix's pledge ooh
it's happening kids got a drinking
problem
i i i feel like i'm in an episode of the
simpsons
where for the first time barney's like
oh beer
where you been on my life you're gonna
watch me become barney gumbel right in
front of you
yes um the general handling of the
project created what i thought was a
negative and not supportive environment
to be clear this is not a simple matter
of us not getting our way
mike and i are collaborative people we
did not need all the ideas to come from
us
as long as we felt those ideas were in
line with the spirit and integrity of
avatar we would have happily embraced
them
however we ultimately came to the belief
that we would not be able to
meaningfully guide the direction of the
series
what do you hear that low key it's like
music
yeah or something oh is that what it is
um well what does that sound like to you
um if if i had to guess i would say
that you know adaptation is a difficult
thing to do
and there's a lot of things that that
have to go by the wayside in order for
one thing to transfer from one medium to
another right
um and it's hard to not kill some
darlings and it's hard
to not have to make sacrifices not hard
to like it's
it's [ __ ] traumatic making that that
that
do you think they had a lot of freedom
in doing it the first time i think they
did exactly what they wanted the first
time
and here they were faced with can we age
them up
can these characters ever romance can
listen or just like that was a cartoon
and this is live action right and they
have different demands when it comes to
story and character and the evolution of
those things
um and you know here's the thing
nobody wants a story like this to be out
because everybody wants
you know hey i want it to be the thing
that i have in my head right
but you know i i've been trying
to think of the adaptations that i love
that the original creators were
intimately involved in
and it's a very small list yeah um you
know it's princess bride
um william goldman wrote the novel and
the screenplay um gone girl
um gillian flynn wrote both of those as
well
but the things that you love that have
transferred from one medium to another
um have been adapted they've been
changed they've been put through a
crucible and
look at the shining you ever read the
book yeah the shining i mean look at the
movie two completely different beasts
but yep both are wonderful
yeah i mean and and that's great that's
awesome that's what should happen i mean
jurassic park
the movie is not jurassic park the novel
is that right yeah i mean there's whole
swaths that are just cut out of it
because you might not have room for it
or it doesn't help but you have to
invent
a you know again here we are in this
little
disney style ride to explain how dna
works
excuse me right um you know
john hammond dies in the book i mean
there's whole there's whole like
hikes that they go on in lord of the
rings that they get cut out there's a
whole character that sings songs and
[ __ ] that nobody needed
because the book is the book and the
movies the movie and in this case the
cartoons the cartoon
and the tv show will be the tv show and
you know so yeah it
it sucks that there's a segment of the
audience including the creators who
don't think that they're getting the
uncut goods
but i mean as as a person who does this
sometimes as a person who has watched it
happen
you know time and time again you have to
let things go and you have to you have
to let it be
what it's going to be and you can't
force it to be something that it is
it sounds like these boys were like look
we just we'd rather not be involved
yeah you know it's like if you're gonna
if you're gonna do things that we can't
understand and can't countenance then
maybe we just
pick up our sticks and go away and to be
fair it's like if i'm them i'm like we
already did it once and it was perfect
yeah so now he would like to do this
again but you don't want it to be as
perfect like i'm not interested in that
yeah i mean there's but they're still
going forward and making it they're
still making it they're still making it
but there's this great quote that i
always
fall back on from i think it's raymond
chandler when he was being interviewed
by some journalist about
how like what is hollywood doing to your
books like how do you how do you deal
with it
and his answer was always uh hollywood
isn't doing anything to them to my books
they're right there on the shelf
if i ever want to look at them that's
where they are my books are fine
you know and i think that was also alan
moore's perspective on the adaptations
what happened from his thing so yeah
v for vendetta is exactly as i remember
it because it's right there on the shelf
and i pick it i read it every year
bat and watchmen like do whatever you
want like the books are fine
i won't take any money for what you do
but i'm also not mad at it
right so i think he seems a little mad
at it
i mean he's a he's an elder god magician
so like
his madness has been channeled into
actual curses truly
um well there it is they're they're gone
they're gone you know and i hope that
she's gone whoa whoa
you know a lot of reasons thank you for
picking up the ball
cause i didn't know the next words
they're off to legend of korra they're
gone but they're gone
what went wrong what else we got um
okay so jared leto wants to make a tron
movie
he's going to be in a tron picture i
heard okay you can't stop the tron
did you see the the you know the other
one they made a couple of legacy
yeah like it's it's i didn't it's a
weird movie
it's gorgeous to look at like it's just
sumptuous
not a lot happens in it really it sounds
like tron
it sounds like yeah it's kind of inert
but really pretty
uh the soundtrack is amazing i wrote to
the soundtrack for like three or four
years
daft punk that punk did the sound yeah
it sounds like they're coming back
um i hope so they didn't do it for the
first try no
because they were daft children at that
point
punks little punks but uh this is
uh return to tron world without jeff
bridges but with jared leto
um yes i have no idea who the hell jared
leto is playing
garrett headland most likely will not
reprise his role as the son of flynn
he won't come back
that's that's my it's like i was asking
like well i don't know about that as if
i've seen
seen it obviously i don't give a [ __ ]
that's my line of the sand i'm more
interested when they're finally going to
talk about you know what you tell me
jared leto wants to play the ship
captain and
i've been a black hole remake
i'm knocking on your door and saying
mark let's go see that movie
but i i didn't see the second tron so
i'm not
hyped to see the next child however that
being said i do want to see what leto
does in morbius
i mean i listen he is a fascinating
actor
i do not always agree with the choices
that he makes
but they're never boring like his
joker's not
boring no i don't like it but it's not
boring yeah i agree with that
you know and when he's great he can be
phenomenal
like one um dallas buyers club
yeah yeah like he's he's actually
fantastic in that movie
and remember was that other movie that
fincher did oh fight club no not
yeah he's in fight club yeah he is but
he's in that other movie right in a
panic room panic
panic room and he's got the cornrows and
[ __ ] he was really
menacing in that movie yeah like the the
his fight club scene is my favorite
where he just gets the [ __ ] kicked out
of him
by ed norton it's like why did you do
that he's like i wanted to destroy
something beautiful yeah
yeah i guess you get jared leto for that
look how pretty he is um all right good
let him make tron yeah
as far as i give a [ __ ] i don't know if
i need another tron in my life i
probably just needed the one
you know all they'll have to do is do
one [ __ ] thing in the trailer that
ties into the old one and i'll be like
oh my god
i'm seeing that and just like tron two
i'll forget to see it
yeah tron not big in my dna and i
appreciate its place in cinematic
history but
leaves me cold i like the video game
more than the movie
now you tell me jared leto wants to
bring back the stand-up tron video game
you got my quarter i'm giving you 25
cents play that game
um i will i will see your 25 cents and
raise you a dollar
is that how much it costs now to play
video games yeah if you can find it have
i showed my age is the egg showing
um what else we got too much jared leto
news
i could use one less jared let on new
stuff if you want me to have stomach any
more jared leto knees i'm gonna need
three more of these i'll be honest with
you
uh here's a rumor it is i'm going to say
it's a rumor that's the rumor
it's rumor patrol it's a foot um so you
know marvel is at some point going to
make x-men movies
yeah um or whatever they call it they
may call it mutants movies because
there was one rumor a while back that
they were looking to phase out the
phrase
x-men because it felt somewhat isolating
to half of the population
why can't there be x people or x mutants
or x mutants wow i never thought of that
yeah
um i don't quite believe it because the
ip is valuable enough that that's
well-known name that would be like
why why are we calling it batman let's
call him bat people yeah bad person yeah
it could be about some [ __ ] you know
it's just about gang
x-men you know i don't bump into that
but then again i'm not
a woman and maybe i don't you know maybe
if i was a woman i'd be like i feel left
out of that
look i feel left out of it because
they're all impossibly in great shape
and i'm not so
[ __ ] i think that's a bias the only
one i could identify with is the [ __ ]
blob and he's a bad guy so
i uh i did see somebody tweet today that
they felt bad for all of the
actors who were supposed to be playing
superheroes and so they're in wicked
crazy good shape
for an indefinite amount of time while
we're all gaining the quarantine 15 and
like that [ __ ] still got to be
shredded like
still holding on like what's her name um
who's playing catwoman
oh yeah yeah she's apparently had to
stay in shape and stuff but rob
pattinson
didn't [ __ ] yeah yeah i'm already
[ __ ] thin what more do you want
um slight aside did you ever watch high
fidelity
i did not but they canceled it they did
and i'm upset you liked it a lot
i liked it quite a bit um and i get it
that sort of disney is beginning to
undergo their own feeling of belt
tightening yeah given that their giant
revenue driver which is
the parks is closed is closed um
but not that one man that was good i saw
her tweet something
um somebody i guess it was tessa
thompson tweeted at her and and
and um what is her name again i'm sorry
zoe kravitz zoe kravitz
i kept wanting to say zoe dishnow that's
the other one that's the other one
zoe kravitz like tweeted back or
something that said uh
it's okay you know they're all those
other
like black female lead shows on hulu
and then she goes oh wait that's funny
um yeah it's a bummer that got canceled
he's a bummer um but that's not the
rumor
the rumor is shia labeouf yeah i want to
talk about this
well then [ __ ] it let's do it because i
saw um uh the tax collector
as well did you yeah it's not the movie
that like everyone thinks it is where
it's just like look at
he's he's [ __ ] shy as all he's second
second lead he's not even the main guy
and i don't want to spoil it but not in
the whole movie oh
interesting but very good does he go off
to the farm
i don't want to spoil it too much
in case people see it but i enjoy it i
thought it was like decent watch a lot
of people
didn't you know gave us some bad reviews
online but i like david's stuff i think
i think he does a good job
i can't do what he does that being said
when i heard this rumor because the
rumor kids is that shia labeouf for
iceman right yes first when i heard the
rumor of shia labeouf i was like oh
that's [ __ ] good because i do think
he's a really good actor
really good actor when i heard iceman i
said
oh all right and i understand because if
they're doing the version of the x-men
from the very first incarnation
they're going to have they're going to
have iceman
angel cyclops beast
and jean grey marvel girl so you know i
could kind of get my head around it but
when they first said shia labeouf for a
marvel movie this is what i says to
myself i says what do you say
wolverine crazy he could totally pull
that off man
like he could and also that dude could
get like ripped but
wolverine doesn't have to be like hugh
jackman big you know what i'm saying
i i think he could pull it off let's
find out
in the chat although i'm gonna need a
sip of courage
[Music]
you let us know in chat if shia labeouf
could be wolverine
would you like that or would you hate
that you want that
i could give that to you no i don't have
any i don't have any play here
but i'm curious to see if other people
thought that was a good idea i talked
about it on jay's live stream on
wednesday and there were a few people
that were like i think that'd be dope
and stuff wolverine shy for wolverine
look i'm happy if he's playing iceman
that's [ __ ] great bobby drake go
ahead
but you tell me he's playing wolverine
holy [ __ ] man
i think he blew up the chat it just went
crazy
with anger nah no [ __ ] no
my bad got back to me
there's a few yeses in there forget i
said it i'm gonna
sell out on my idea right now turn code
and say with the rest of you no way no i
will take back this
courage yeah what the [ __ ] will you let
me go
you ruined my judgment you done me wrong
i lost my credibility whoever said that
alcohol
smudges judgment i thought this was
gonna make me appealing
and smart and smart and doing good on
tests
you guys are jerks all i need is this
i'm gonna cry in myself all right never
mind i even said it never mind because i
don't want this showing up on
comicbook.com
where they're like smith all in for shia
labeouf as wolverine
and then the internet kind of goes at me
i'm 50 years old now i don't need that
[ __ ]
like i don't know how the internet works
anymore once you click over the 50s it's
all
[ __ ] all it's all math to me now yeah
there's also a contingent that's like
hey so if we're
also doing the ice man who's gay then
is bobby drake in the comics yes when
did that happen
a few years seven years ago yeah good um
good for him
they were like hey would it be great if
you could get a gay actor to play a gay
character in a superhero movie
and uh and that would make some sense
i like shaya in the abstract it has been
a long time since i've left how about we
make him
cyclops since we're in charge how about
we make him cyclops he could be an
intense cyclops
he could totally be an intense cyclops
but you kind of want to see his eye he's
a good actor
really good actor watch that [ __ ]
honeyboy movie
he plays his dad holy [ __ ] man it also
makes you go
you feel bad for him as a kid have you
ever seen the battle for shaker heights
i did years ago yeah yes yes i did
[ __ ] project green is a cute movie um
all right so uh what are they saying in
the chat is he problematic or they just
don't like the idea
of him playing logan weapon x i think
they just don't
like the idea of him playing anybody
that people love
what it looks who do they want hey chat
who do you guys want to see as wolverine
and don't say hugh jackman
a lot of zac efron for wolverine
well i mean here's here's what i'll say
like he did this
documentary sort of yeah where he just
got his thick body yeah like he's and he
talked about
that a lot of people said dad bottom
like no i have a dad bod
hold on this guy's just thick with two
c's right
he just like started eating carbs again
yes and
muscle and [ __ ] so yeah maybe he could
you know he's got like a beard and he's
looking all
i could i could see that who else seen
some tom hardy's
in there well [ __ ] of course man tom
hardy for
everything tom hardy for magneto
cyclops logan like one-man show
tom hardy plays all the [ __ ] roles uh
seeing some
uh taryn eggerton from yeah
rocket man and uh kingsman kingsman i'm
not that i think he's a good actor but i
don't see
it that doesn't doesn't he doesn't
strike me as wolverine
i'm sure he's like you don't even strike
me as a [ __ ] director mate i'm like
right on right on
uh some uh i saw
joe i'm going to butcher his life
manganillo
joe manganello i mean look joe
manganello for everything all day he's
cut from god's own wood and he's a nice
guy and he's a real good actor
um but this is going to sound weird he
might be too tall
to play wolverine i mean i don't i don't
know the height range
i've never seen a lineup that had joe
manganello and hugh jackman in it but
hugh jackman he's not a short dude
either
he's joe magnel is definitely taller
than hugh jackman yeah for sure
i mean couldn't you just call peter
jackson and teach him how to
have teach you how to shrink people like
just force perspective the [ __ ] out of
him you know who joey joe maganelo would
be great
sabertooth oh yeah yeah
because it give him a chance to play the
bad guy remember he was going to be
deathstroke for a minute there
i'm i'm looking forward to the next
iteration of bob hoskins to come and
play the role
that fans like the very first fan
casting was like was bob hospital was
bob hoskins has wolverine
um so yeah let's dig him up i'll tell
you what it ain't gonna be based on our
chat shia labeouf
don't think so i really thought i was
onto something there you know it's it's
the bud light salsa talking it's just
what it was
you made me think i was a hero you're
lying piece of [ __ ]
what else we got um this was a story
that we
would have talked about last week had we
had a show but we didn't
we took last week off you guys didn't
notice um
the thing we were talking about whether
would ever happen or not
seems to be happening which is a giant
200 million dollar blockbuster franchise
movie
going straight to a stream this is big
news
big news um and there had been a lot of
sort of like
playing chicken with release dates and
theater counts and
you know tennant was the sort of big
like we're coming hopeful we're not oh
we're gonna do it coming they're not
even breathing hard
not even really not um but mulan
disney's massive like a graphic one up
when you said mulan well done andrew
look at andrew's in there just killing
it [ __ ] hey man this [ __ ]
this show's getting better just keep
putting up graphics stop showing us
um disney disney has pulled the trigger
and decided that mulan will be going to
disney plus
now that you know on the surface you're
like well great
i'm already a disney plus subscriber so
i'm gonna
sit down grab my [ __ ] corn and watch
the [ __ ] out of some mulan
foc free of charge am i right uh you
might think so
but what hold on i need a drink if
you're going to tell me i got to pay
more money for this milan movie
i am wasting this god's own nectar
yeah no it's good uh it will char it
will cost you
29.99 so in addition to whatever you pay
monthly for
disney plus uh you also have to pay for
that move do you own it after that
um you you have access to it for as long
as you're a disney plus subscriber
so technically you own it in your disney
plus library right it's not a one-time
rental
you you can watch it a thousand times
with your kids because they will have
nothing else to watch
um and it vanishes from your access if
you
ever let your let your membership laugh
how do you feel about the 30 buck
premium
um i think it makes a ton of sense i do
too but a lot of people online pissed
i mean a lot of people in line are
pissed because if i have to guess
they're just not used to paying that
much money for a thing that you watch at
home yeah
especially the thing you watch via
streamer which had
traditionally always been i paid you my
[ __ ] fee just give me the thing i
want
but you would have if you're if you're
going to see milan odds are
you have a family yes and if you have
that family it's you
and you take mark he's got two small
kids i've got well
relatively you know kids that still go
to the movies and [ __ ] kids that still
like their parents because they live
with them they have to like them
they have no choice but to go where i
take them so if you all want to go see
milan
it's 100 bucks right there easy you know
and
or and if you're going and buying like
popcorn and
whatever two hundred dollars it could
get high like [ __ ] the snacks are
[ __ ] more pricey
more prices but yeah you'd look at it
you know in la it might be more
expensive other places
15 bucks a ticket easy so that's 60
just in tickets another 40 bucks in soda
and popcorn and candy
parking potentially yes not a babysitter
because you're taking the kids
but you're in 100 bucks and you got to
see it once
and here and you've caught covet in the
process and you caught [ __ ] coven in
the process
this way you get to see it for for
easily a third of that cost
you can watch it as much times as you
want to and unless you are
actively seeking out kovid you don't
have to walk into its path
in your living room makes sense now
problem with this not a problem but
if this does bang up business
this is what we're going to see for the
next year all the biggies
are going to start coming streaming
yeah including black widow probably
black widow i mean and this is disney so
disney's already this is them peeling
off
and that mulan movie was not cheap and i
would venture to say might be more
expensive than the black widow picture i
think it probably was
so if they wind up making a pretty penny
off of this
you're going to see black widow a lot
sooner than you thought you would you
know who did see it already zach braff
black widow or mulan uh black widow
really yeah i saw somebody on twitter
like zach braff saw black widow i'm like
how the [ __ ] did that happen seriously
who the [ __ ] is black breath to get into
black brittle somebody really liked
gardening yeah really what about us
come on um this is uh
this mark is where the rubber meets the
road as they say
indeed this is the thing that uh the
the shall not be named the thing that
exhibitors
fear the most when studios start taking
a premium picture
and skipping theatrical exhibition
but what else you going to do otherwise
it's going to sit in a can for a year
yeah i mean and it's one of two stories
that happened in the last week or so
um that may drastically change the way
we experience the theatrical
exhibition experience what was the other
one the other one was there was a law in
the books that i think had been there
for like 70 years it was called like the
paramount ruling
oh yes which ultimately said that uh
that
you had to have a set yet to break the
theatrical distribution chain
which is studios could not own theaters
yeah it was you could own the means of
production you could own the means of
distribution but you could not own the
means of exhibition right
and that's where because otherwise it's
a monopoly otherwise it's a monopoly
otherwise you can decide
hey if disney owns this theater which
they own one like they only el capitan
and netflix guess what they never show
there they don't show anything but
disney movies
um and so what happens if amc which is
currently on the verge of bankruptcy
decides let's sell to disney and disney
owns amc
now they were probably in some amc's in
in you know new york la chicago main
cities
sure you might get other studio pictures
in there
but like do you think that they're going
to let black widow open opposite wonder
woman 2
even the next week after no not in those
theaters
you'd probably have to wait a couple of
weeks for that and if there's no other
choice for you if you live in the middle
of america if you live in some town that
doesn't have nine different theaters
you've only got an amc and it's now
owned by disney
do you get to see the other [ __ ] you
want to see when you're taking a drive
to regal cinemas or something like that
national amusements
totally you know well will amazon just
buy up a [ __ ] theater chat probably
probably so will netflix
netflix definitely they already bought
the egyptian out here yeah
you know so like in some in some ways of
looking at it it's great like [ __ ]
netflix owns a movie theater now they
can put their [ __ ] in movies and now you
can
you can have that experience with
extraction or old guard or whatever
right awesome but it becomes incredibly
problematic when you're dealing with
competition
and how who you're letting play in your
theaters what are the windows for that
exhibition
and who's controlling what you as the
audience gets to see it's no longer a
free market economy
as a moviegoer you are now subject to
the whims of who owns what theater and
what's playing in it things have changed
so who the [ __ ] knows what movie going
looks like
in five years i'd be concerned but i'm
more concerned about will we have a post
office in five years mark
yes hopefully if anna's amazon's gonna
buy anything
it's the united states post office
except take it out of the hands of
[ __ ] people that don't seem to want
it yeah except that once amazon gets a
post office then
then it's amazon's post office that's
fine i like getting my packages in a
priority fashion
um except that's illegal yeah some look
somebody saved the post office
um one a couple of little quick hits
okay patty jenkins has uh said lovely
person
lovely absolutely i've never met her
wonderful everything i've read about her
she seems classy talented human being
man
anyway what's going on um she feels like
she's been cancelled i'm like no
she's great don't take her from me i
just put all my eggs in her basket hey
there's a picture of her working hey put
it back up
yeah there she is working that's what
she does for a living she tells wonder
woman what to do
she does but she may stop telling wonder
woman what to do after wonder woman
three
the what um who are these people that
walk away from sure things
well i'll never understand that let me
tell you if i had wonder woman
one and it was what it was yeah they
couldn't they it'd take a [ __ ]
golden lariat to pull me off of wonder
woman 96.
i'd be like what are we doing this year
they're like we don't want you to do
this anymore i'm like come on i did it
right once
we're kind of going to stop making these
at some point no
you guys suck um she leaving well i mean
she did say that you know she thinks
that the story she wants to tell with
diana
is a three-part story great and then
tell another one
and then some more until another then
tell another then tell another and like
after 50 years you're done yeah yeah
no she thinks well i'll tell you what
when she's done i'll take it
you got this let me take a crack at it
all right
uh since i'm not a lady we'll have to
change the title to wonder man do you
think that'll work
just wonder person will marvel let that
movie happen
wonder man they have that that they do
um
so yeah it's it's great for her if she
gets to tell and complete the cycle that
you want
she shows a great deal of restraint that
she's like yeah i'll leave after three
um but it would be it i would be
saddened
if with wonder woman three behind her
she's out of the dc comics fold agreed
um make something else make something
else like lock her down give her one of
those
giant overall exclusive deals and don't
let her go give her
more give her more more of everything
yeah she's pretty good
less of all the other [ __ ] give patty
more more and more and more
don't show her the door hide the door
i mean don't keep her there against her
[ __ ] will that'd be terrible but
she's a talented lady hold that door no
door hold the door
hold the door uh sean smith in chat
echoes your thoughts on paddy jenkins
and said
that patty helped his gofundme with five
thousand dollars out of the kindness of
her heart
like i think he had some medical issues
and patty jenkins donated five thousand
dollars
so that's proof is in the money where
her mouth is money where the mouth is
i'm telling you she's a classy
wonderful lady man and and she made a
hell of a picture she also i love that
monster movie too
um she's not uh she's no joke she's for
real but that makes me sad that she'll
eventually leave i i just don't
understand that mindset
like milk it till you're talking to the
guy who still talks about clerks
anyway uh the last story of the night
uh oh yes no it's not a bad one
amc um the network or the failing movie
theater that's about to be bought by
disney the failing movie theater
conglomerate
um is attempting to reopen on
august 20th so
next friday they better not charge a lot
for tickets i'll tell you that much
it does not seem as if they're going to
what do you mean it seems as if in
celebration
of some uh [ __ ] 100th anniversary
right they're going to charge the same
ticket price that you would have paid
in 1920 to go to a movie theater how
much 15 cents
i mean i bet you all the theater studios
are happy about that
i mean are these old movies they're
showing um
yeah i mean they're gonna play catalog
movies like black panther back to the
future in
greece nothing new um i don't
think so um that 15 cents a loss leader
right it's like you show the movie for
pennies because you know they're coming
in to buy some popcorn and soda and
that's what you're making money on
problem is
you start doing this [ __ ] where you're
like we'll only charge you 15 cents
when they start showing black widow i'm
gonna show up and be like hey 15
cents that's what i pay that's what you
said
it's like i'm gonna pay 15 cents and
then i want to refund because i don't
like this movie
and i want a pass to come to see any
other [ __ ] movie i want and i want to
go see black widow
three nickels right now i'm waiting
um it's uh it's an ingenious plan
um but i don't know uh
if anyone's willing to go sit in a small
room
with a bunch of breathers right now um
my life is worth more than 15 cents i'd
like to think
i guess that's what they're saying
they're like look we understand it's
risky so the movie will only cost you 15
cents
that way when you're sitting in a
hospital talking to people
on a respirator you could be like i paid
15 cents to see grease again
you could have watched it could wash it
at home luckily i got that other 1485 in
my pocket
to help pay for these medical bills
um you know i guess it's a very nice
gesture
it's an interesting stunt we'll see if
uh if it pays off
yeah i can't imagine they would be doing
that in
any other time like let's say nothing
went wrong and
2020 was just as wonderful as 2019 for
the most part and stuff no covet and
[ __ ] like that
do you think they really would have been
like it's our birthday 15 cent movies or
they're like it's our birthday
soda costs double yeah i i you know i
remember when
nathan's had their like hundredth
birthday and they were given like five
dollar hot dogs
five cent hot dogs sorry yeah five seven
five dollars for nathan's are you out of
your mind
is this the future that's what they pay
now yeah
uh five cent hot dogs like that's cool
and marketing and you can
you know write it all off as a marketing
experience plus it costs two cents to
make a hot dog
so there you go so you just take the
parts of the meat that aren't in
anything else that you want to eat grind
it up and put it in its own stomach
bucket make it a make it a tube steak
put in a big condom and then serve it to
people
um that's all the news that's all it is
my friend give it up for mark he brought
you the news
jc we come to that point of the show
where we're gonna answer questions but i
ain't doing that until i get another one
of these
don't give him anymore give me another
one jc
okay i'm gonna end up driving
i'm tired of this i just
i always lock my files thank you
what is it
what is that of the postman what about
it
yeah good point andrew's saying that if
they're gonna show 15 cent movies
show the postman donate the money back
to the usps i mean basically
like thanks for the 15 cents you jerks
we're trying to save the [ __ ] boss
it's like the quarter of a cost of a
stamp
postman that's a movie worth watching
kids re-watch it and we can watch out
kevin costner predicted the future
between postman water world and no way
out that's true
oh my god you're right russians weather
and [ __ ] post-op post offices [ __ ]
god damn it costner no wonder
when he played paw ken he was like no no
no just let me die
because i've ruined america it's my
fault
um all right question one jc what do
they want to know what can we tell them
uh jeremiah once was a bullfrog
yes was a good friend of mine never
understood a single word he said but he
helped me drink my bud light black
cherry
seltzer god damn i love jeremiah joy to
the world jeremiah
[Laughter]
he uh usually when this show goes off
the rails
you like forget [ __ ] like you have the
weed head and you're like
where was i but it's always very like
sedate and docile
not now i forgot now it's loud
i'm here and i got my drinks i don't
need nobody but you
all right what does jeremiah want to
know uh he says given the fact the
original three cast members of jurassic
park are
back story wise yes how does colin
trevaro
stick the landing with this
jurassic park or jurassic world dominion
i think rather well i've enjoyed both of
those movies i know he did the one and
he didn't do the second one he produced
it or whatever but
i i think there's no way those movies
were enjoyable without the three leads
from jurassic park now you're bringing
them back
i'm in um bring back sam jackson and and
uh
newman the postman as well mind your
butts yeah bring them all back
they better bring back the kids as well
right
joey was his name maserato or whatever
played the little kid and the girl yeah
i mean
didn't they come back the one girl came
back for like two they talked to him for
like two seconds at one point
in the house and then they were going
bring those kids back man because that
one kid was in a movie fairly recently
he was in uh the queen movie bohemian
rhapsody was he
he was the drummer in bohemian rhapsody
if i remember correctly
bass player my bad andrew's got us
covered was that [ __ ] kid
that's the bud light talking i'm like he
was the drummer
like he was the bass player
uh yeah he'll do it he's gonna stick the
landing
if you're asking me what he's gonna do i
don't know if i was creative enough to
invent a
[ __ ] jurassic park script you think
i'd be sitting here doing a podcast in
an empty bar
[ __ ] no i'd be making dinosaur movies
over the hill
what do you think uh i mean i hope he
sticks the landing i don't i can't say
for certain if he will or he won't
um but clearly the dak is stacked to do
so because this this is a
franchise that seems to run on nostalgia
yes very much so
and you bring back those three kids you
got all the nostalgias
yeah so it feels as if they're they're
doubling down on what works for them
and nine times out of ten that's uh
that's a key to at the very least a good
time at the movies
i think we're gonna get a grade a
picture from colin trevorrow
the man of tomorrow there you go this
movie preview is brought to you by bud
lightsaber
you know what movie's good dinosaur land
i think that's what it's called that is
orlandia
my favorite movie dinosaur landia
fred armisen's dinosaur landia
uh all right number two that was
jeremiah jeremiah you have a great
[ __ ] night who's next
all right these are kind of uh relevant
in a way you'll see where they're coming
from
beijider beijider wants to know who is
on the mount rushmore of comics
of comics of comics so far like stand-up
comics or comic books comic
books the mount rushmore of comic books
four figures who would be in
or for comic books uh
he's just of comic books action comics
number one detective
comics titles and not people totally
that's what i'm going for action comics
number one the first appearance of
superman
detective comics 27 the first appearance
of batman amazing fantasy number
15. uh first appearance of spider-man
and fourth place
i mean you know i should be like the guy
who created the yellow kid because that
was like
you know [ __ ] historically important
to the realm of comic books but
personally it doesn't do much for me um
giant-sized x-men annual perhaps
the birth of the modern day comic book
era
those are my four and mind you
i don't put those four because i'm like
because they all mean
a lot to me but i think those are four
pretty important comic books in comic
book history what about you
i'm going to do the literal version of
mount rushmore
people okay will eisner
oh the people who created comics will
eisner creator of the spirit
stan lee stan lee creator of your entire
happy childhood
and adulthood uh harvey kurtzman
harvey kurtzman uh ec comics and
mad magazine uh
[ __ ] bill gaines or he's covered by
yeah maybe it's bill gaines or harvey
one of those two but
or you know what give it let siegel and
schuster
share a spot without him you go you
don't get superheroes
they birthed the modern day superhero
and never got credit in this lifetime
right till the very end so maybe like
one of the faces half siegel half
shuster
i ain't going to tell you what to do
with your mountain it's my mountain
um no i like that because it would be
good to have just pure creators
on that and not just editors or
publishers agreed thanking will eisner
was also pure creator that's a good
question
well done um yeah and i like that i like
that
only four we got four only four you know
i i
i don't know enough about the sort of
deep history of comics to know if there
should be a woman on that list um my
guess is there should be
always um but you know as
sadly we are the the benefit the the
inheritors of a history that was written
by men
so it's it's unsure who that woman would
be um
but there should be one and there should
probably be a black dude on there
but uh you know it's hard it's
that's a history we just don't know so
that's that would be my guess
those are my those are my four segal
shuster will eisner
um stan lee
and max games harvey kurtzman bill
gaines
harvard kurtzman yeah uh there it is off
our
dick you got the answer you wanted it
maybe not the one you wanted but you got
a good answer from a good man
leave him alone he's a good man go
all right uh chase hunter is interested
in knowing
which chase hunter dc's time traveler
that alan moore
based his entire twilight of the
superheroes around rip hunter
[ __ ] most likely
what does chase hunter want to know he's
like where's my uncle rip
he's lost in time help me
he uh he's interested in knowing which
fictional character
would you want to run for president of
the united states
oh what a great question nice
work that is that's a fantastic question
okay and fictional character
crosstalk fictional character and then
maybe we put them on
mount rushmore um
can i pick a few yeah now could they
have what is there a rule against them
having previously paid presidents
or having been presidents could can we
choose fictional presidents
talk here go ahead okay yeah just
checking barack obama is not fictional
aye
number one barack obama uh fictional
characters
or former presidents i don't know what
mark's
building toward he wants taft back go
figure he's a big taft guy
um let me see
all right here you go i know it's not
legal because he's from england but
harry potter
because he's magic we wouldn't have this
cove and [ __ ] he'd be like
evaporator kiss and it'd be gone he
could cure us all
some little polyjuice potion like a 14
year old
yes look is it any worse than what we've
been dealing with for four years
i'll take a [ __ ] real 14 year old boy
who happens to know some magic
the juan chooses the wizard mark and the
wizard chooses the office
and the office is the highest in the
land in america
even though he's a little british boy
that's one of my presidents the other
not bruce wayne batman
president batman you would see some [ __ ]
get done there would never be a boring
[ __ ]
meeting and he'd be bringing you live
action justice
you think there'd be like these [ __ ]
like covet briefings
they would start the covet briefing he'd
just be fighting the covet in the air
batman beating the [ __ ] out of coven
we're all like thank you president
batman
wouldn't even matter that most people
don't know his identity but me and mark
happen to know that it's
spoilers bruce wayne um so batman
president batman
let me see yoda
you said fictional characters who's
wiser than yoda
plus he can lift rocks so you know the
white house garden is going to look
amazing
um yoda although all day yoda
baby yoda as vice president because then
when old man yoda drops dead
you got babies slide him right out
exactly slides right in
there uh hold on let me let me you know
let me
let me go beyond that um wonder woman
princess diana i don't know if there's
laws because like she was born
you know on themyscira or whatever but i
mean you already got a 14 year old
british boy so
why not you're right wow [ __ ] it you're
absolutely right so
diana princess of themyscira president
of the united states she's already got
the outfit
it's got the flag all over it she does
and linda carter has played the
president of the united states for
i directed her as such in supergirl well
done um
let's see wonder woman's also got the
lasso of truth
so when people you know lying's not a
thing in politics but if it were
she'd be able to they always tell me
that was
adorable delivery where jay-z was like
lying's not a thing in politics
that was awesome um yes diana with a
magic lasso of truth
[ __ ] you get to the bottom of any any
hearings
you know what i'm saying uh those are my
choices
if you don't like it you can get the
[ __ ] out
all i need is this what do you got i'm
not sure how to follow that
with like i think laura roslin would be
an excellent president that's a great
choice she was a great president and i
know because she's a legit president
person versus a government worker not a
four-year-old boy with a wand
but okay um oh your fictional
character's better than mine that's what
you're saying no
i'm saying i didn't realize we were
playing quite so fast and loose
with sanity but the show is called fat
man beyond what do you think we're here
trying to figure out the salt 2
treaty just [ __ ] say i don't know
voldemort move on
uh professor x [ __ ] great idea oh my god
that's great because then you can just
make the people do what you want puts on
cerebro
and we're good to go yes um jed bartlett
martin sheen from west wing oh my god
the idealistic fake president you're
absolutely right totally if i'm gonna
live in a fiction
i want that to be my fiction and he'll
always be speaking in like aaron sorkin
[ __ ] monologue
totally love it um and conan the
barbarian
because nobody doesn't pass a law that
conan once passed
that's true and then you see him at his
presidential address
where no he's doing his [ __ ]
presidential covet briefing and they're
like uh mr president
what is best in life
and he's like oh my god i'm so ready for
this one yes
uh to to to destroy your enemies no what
is it crush your enemies
see them driven before you and you're
the lamentation of the women
it's like you can't say the last part so
much why
i'm president
he does not vote to hell with him that
is a great [ __ ] that's a great that's
true
one nation under crime indivisible
with liberty and painful that's his
that's his swearing-in address where
he's got his hand on the bible he's like
krom i do not pray to you i have no
tongue for it people are like is this
they changed the [ __ ] swearing oh
this got very metal they're like you
shut the [ __ ] up this is the most metal
[ __ ] inauguration
i've ever been in in my life there are
vultures circling over
once he's [ __ ] once he's canonized as
president they're like
hang him on the tree of woe
or like beastmaster would also be a good
president
yeah i was watching that the other day
that holds up but conan was
[ __ ] that's hot you're right there's
nothing no law not being passed
and also by the end of conan he wasn't
you know such an [ __ ] anymore he they
showed him gray-haired and wizards
so all right not so much conan the
barbarian but king conan king conan
because otherwise if you get conan the
barbarians punching camels in the faces
that is not a photo opportunity that
anybody wants no that's how you lose
that office i was always fond of the
fact that arnold schwarzenegger kept his
conan sword
in his office when he was governor of
california that's kind of dope
isn't that great like you're walking in
to see the governor and he's just got
this [ __ ]
giant broadsword that's how we all learn
to use a sword watching him do it in
conan
uh those are my presidents come to me my
child how about falsehood
we're already at that presidency we know
what that one's like
pretty much um who asked that question
chase hunter challenger of the unknown
came from the past or the future to ask
that question chase hunter did
let me tell you something give me the
camera come back to me
give it to him come back come back to me
when i go home tonight and i put my head
on a pillow and finally go to sleep you
know what i'm gonna be thinking of
chase [ __ ] hunter i'm gonna wake up
my wife and be like
hey who do you think good fictional
president would be chase hunter wants to
know she'll be like what the [ __ ]
who are you talking about i'm like chase
hunter oh this marriage is over and i'll
get divorced
because of my love for chase hunter
that's how good that you [ __ ] it all
up chase
yeah it was look we had a good thing
going for two decades but this is a
better thing
my wife never asked me a question like
that she always asked me [ __ ] like how
come you're not you know better at what
you do
how come you're not chase hunter yeah
like that's right
tired of getting that question um thank
you for that question that was great
there's three questions we got them all
we gave you the news we [ __ ] drank
together
what more do you want it's saturday
night you get to go enjoy the rest of it
man
you get to what do you do movies
thank you movies ladies and gentlemen
thank you andrew movies closes tomorrow
ladies and gentlemen look at the picture
of those two youngsters man he just
wanted to talk about it because he went
and pulled the picture for it i'm glad
[ __ ] look at the work i did in
the future andrew more
graphics including full frontal nudity
please
because we can always have things to
talk about like this
kids that's a labia you know what that
is batman likes that too
that will make it you know it'll be in
here
that nudity really pulled the room
together boobies
is closing tomorrow in los angeles for
pop-in purposes so
this is your last chance to go into it
um we were meant to be open for a month
and we wound up doing two months
they will be doing uh food delivery
still on post mates
and of course anywhere in the united
states go type into your browsers right
now
moviespopup.com and you can order
yourself
a movie meal kit anywhere in the us gold
belly will send it to you
then we're closing in la
all good things come to an end but we
may be going someplace else soon and
i'll tell you about
that this week hogwarts
absolutely that they need a movie is bad
they really do
um so yes movies uh closes tomorrow man
thank you
to all of los angeles for what a
wonderful experience it was and
and uh it's it's created excitement to
bring it into
other places in the world and we never
saw that coming so thank you that was
really [ __ ] cool
um what else can we give them
nothing that's it that's all you got
enough [ __ ] what more do you want
everybody grab your bud light seltzers
and let's raise
raise toast to president harry potter
to the bride to the bride to the bride
to the bride
to the groom
hopefully this ain't that red wedding
[ __ ] where one of us gets stabbed in the
gut right afterwards and [ __ ] uh well
that ally you never can tell
that's true [ __ ] if you hear that song
if we start hearing the reigns of
castamere
[ __ ] run that's what i know is that
the reigns of casting
run or is that just toto soundtrack from
dune
i can't be certain is that the reign of
castmeres that i hear is that a knife in
your
is that a knife in my stomach are you
just happy to see me yes are we blaming
it on the rain by oranges jones
blame it on the rain whole different
scene with that song
totally if that starts playing then
they're more alarmed going like these
tunes sound out of place
i don't understand um black dude in the
corner who let him into westeros
you can tell right now that the bud
light seltzer's kicking in because we're
making an even worse version of game of
thrones than they did in the final
season kids
and that's saying something so uh this
week on tuesday is the final episode of
celebrity show off you can see
if uh we win or not i happen to know
what happened not gonna spoil it here
you can't read this face at all
so wait it's not live no that's never
live
most tv is not it isn't hold on they're
not in my box in my house
can you believe that they don't let us
out afterwards pre-taped this is
[ __ ]
no live studio audiences either i was
led to believe otherwise
tv nothing but lies entertainment
business full of lies that's why we
cover it here
every week to bring you the goddamn
truth you know the truth is
this week a lot of sad people don't have
jobs at dc comics
indeed our hearts go out to those folks
those folks helped tell us the stories
that shaped our life some
bobby chase been there for a [ __ ]
damn minute hell yeah i saw her name in
comic books when i was just reading
comic books so
heart goes out to all those [ __ ]
people man nobody wants seeing by losing
jobs
and to you know the rest of america
we're still enduring
sort of historic job losses and it's
it's
insane and so if you're struggling if
you're out there and just trying to make
ends meet we appreciate you spending
some time with us
absolutely on this night and uh glad to
do it
without charging a little free
entertainment
people will like pay for people like i
wouldn't pay for this [ __ ] anyway with
good reason
president bartlett that's who he [ __ ]
picks sorry
i also gave you conan that's true that
was [ __ ] metal it was the most
metal presidential choice of all time uh
there it is kids [ __ ] good times were
had
drinks were [ __ ] had jc led us
into the bar andrew pulled every graphic
imaginable and threw it up online for
you to see
like a boss um mark went dumpster diving
for the news
and [ __ ] found all the news this [ __ ]
to print
and that's all you've got ladies and
gentlemen how close we are
far away so close uh when the show's
over we're gonna [ __ ]
leave it on the glass i haven't been
cheek to cheek with kevin since
oh vancouver now we can i know thanks to
jc
um there it is kids come back anytime
we'll be here you'll find us we're the
two at the bar drinking bud light
seltzers we're just gonna start live
streaming everything
we're like cam girls put them on a glass
just here all [ __ ] day
tip jar is right in the corner tell us
what to drink and we'll drink it
there it is ladies and gentlemen yeah it
is fat man beyond
i'm kevin smith i'm mark bernard tune in
next time same
fat time same fat channel smodcast.com
or
youtube.com bud light for the good of
all cree and everybody who likes a
smooth crisp seltzer booze drink
so say we all native
you